au débat de ce club un consacré aux
énergies Alex pour commencer ce débat
pour poser la chose on va faire un point
avec vous sur la place des énergies
renouvelables aujourd'hui en France et
oui un chiffre Oriane pour commencer les
énergies renouvelables représentent
aujourd'hui plus de 19% de notre
consommation finale d'énergie en France
c'est un chiffre qui est plutôt mauvais
qui ne respecte pas les objectifs de
l'Union européenne actuellement qui fixe
la barre à 24% donc la France est à la
traîne dans ce domaine et puis on va
essayer de mieux voir la répartition
entre ces différentes énergies
renouvelables on peut rappeler que le
bois énergie représente plus d'un tiers
de ces énergies l'hydraulique 16%, une
dizaine de % pour d'un côté les pompes à
chaleur et de l'autre l'éolien en
revanche le solaire et peut développer
en France et représente 4% de ces
énergies renouvelables voilà pour les
chiffres on va venir dans quelques
instants sur le texte mais d'abord Alex
l'a dit on est en retard sur les
énergies renouvelables pourquoi ce
retard selon vous
par le fait que la France avait mis tous
ses œufs dans le même panier le panier
du nucléaire et qu'elle n'a pas vu
l'évolution du monde c'est la France
c'est une citadelle assiégée aujourd'hui
qui a raté ce qui est quand même le
développement mondial principal 90% de
des investissements dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui sur l'énergie sont sur les
énergies renouvelables les géants de la
chimie allemand investissent massivement
sur les parcs et Oli en short et nous on
a raté effectivement
cette évolution quelle évolution
mondiale est vraiment beaucoup parent
dogmatisme alors maintenant la question
c'est la question de ce projet de loi
est-ce qu'on est capable de rattraper ce
retard et redevenir une nation
industrielle qui qui compte en termes
énergétique
évidemment pour vous aussi c'est du
dogmatisme on en a trop fait sur le
nucléaire et pas assez sur le
renouvelable c'est exactement le
contraire la réalité c'est qu'il faut
lutter pour décarboner l'énergie en
général l'industrie le logement les
transports la solution la réponse et
l'électricité une électricité massive
une électricité décar une électricité
pilotable c'est-à-dire que l'on peut
mobiliser lorsque l'on en a besoin et
c'est en effet le nucléaire qui est la
bonne solution alors là où
mon excellent collègue n'a pas
complètement tort c'est que depuis 10
ans les gouvernements successifs ont nié
cette évidence pour décarboner il faut
investir et investir continuer
d'investir dans le nucléaire qui est la
solution la plus maîtrisée la plus
raisonnable pour obtenir la
décarbonation qui est la priorité le
renouvelable est très séduisant il n'est
pas pilotable sauf peut-être
l'hydraulique au cours de l'eau mais le
bois énergie est une forme très
marginale le soleil
sous la forme éolienne puisque après
tout le vent c'est le soleil
c'est très intéressant mais il y a des
saturations de sites et il y a une
invisibilité un caractère intermittent
et aléatoire le photovoltaïque est utile
naturellement mais là encore le
photovoltaïque faute de stockage
d'énergie ne fonctionne qu'une partie de
du temps quand il y a du soleil et un
soleil qui est variable et donc le
nucléaire et la condition indispensable
du renouvelable et de la décarbonation
si on n'aime pas le nucléaire je
comprends très bien mais on ne peut pas
prétendre des carboner et d'ailleurs
vous vous dites la France est en retard
en retard par rapport à quoi par rapport
à l'énergie carbonée que produit
l'Allemagne mais c'est parfaitement
scandaleux l'Europe est totalement
irrespensable elle nous dit faites du
renouvelable et en réalité c'est que
l'on fait du carboné
par l'Union européenne mais l'Union
européenne doit choisir
faire de l'idéologie du renouvelable ou
au contraire décarboner la priorité j'ai
cru comprendre c'était de décarboner
l'énergie sous toutes ses formes et sur
tous ces et c'est le nucléaire
on sent un peu le vent de panique je
sais pas si c'est le soleil qui provoque
le vent de panique mais enfin moi je
suis un bon père de famille quand on les
Anglais achètent aujourd'hui du
mégawattheure de grand éolien Auchan à
40 € et que le nucléaire le nouvel ePER
sort à peu près à 120 euros c'est-à-dire
3 fois plus cher tu es encore beaucoup
plus cher qu'avec le stockage
d'hydrogène
adossé à l'éolien qui est en train de se
développer notamment à Saint-Nazaire on
a inauguré aussi
la semaine dernière les premières qui
sont de production d'hydrogène adossée à
l'éolien en fait on est dans un discours
totalement
irréel qui ne correspond pas aux
analyses de Bloomberg en fait à
l'analyse du grand capital européen qui
investit massivement les Écossais vont
mettre 50 gigawatts d'éolien offshore et
ils sont en train d'investir massivement
on arrive pratiquement rien qu'à au
niveau de l'Écosse à la CAP décidé du
parc nucléaire français c'est-à-dire on
s'entête enfin ou certains s'entêtent
mais moins le gouvernement avec ce
projet de loi et moi je parle je pense
que c'est du projet loi qu'il faut
parler il faut pas parler de
science-fiction et du grand retour du
nucléaire dans 15 ans ça sera trop tard
de toute manière donc il faut se
focaliser sur ce projet de aujourd'hui
et pas faire de l'assurance fiction IRL
sur un nucléaire qui n'existe pas
notamment les SMS moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on a une question en
France qui est rattraper le retard tenir
les objectifs européens ça passe par
l'éolien ça passe par le photovoltaïque
c'est un projet de loi qui est un peu
responsable pour une fois c'est bien
l'état dit effectivement
on a raté le coche et dans la situation
de crise énergétique dans laquelle on
est il n'y a que le renouvelable donc
comment fait-on au mieux comment fait-on
pour faire en sorte aussi qu'on protège
l'environnement et la deuxième mouture
du projet de loi là dessus va dans le
bon sens et entendu la vie des Assions
de protection de l'environnement je
crois qu'il faut parler du présent et
pas partir dans un débat totalement
irréel et théorique sur le nucléaire de
demain qui n'existe pas on va parler de
ce texte on va parler du nucléaire mais
on va parler de ce texte projet de
l'énergie renouvelable il est tout est
présenté hier en conseil des ministres à
Alex et vise à accélérer le
développement de ces énergies et oui car
nos projets d'énergie renouvelables
mettent du temps à se mettre en place on
peut prendre l'exemple allemand qui fait
un petit peu mal par exemple pour
installer un site éolien offshore en
France il faut 10 ans en moyenne en
Allemagne c'est 5 ans et pour installer
un site éolien terrestre 7 ans en
moyenne en France trois ans en Allemagne
donc face à ce retard et bien Emmanuel
Macron veut fixer de nouveaux objectifs
on va l'écouter
trois ans pour un projet photovoltaïque
c'est un bon objectif pour les petits
projets on doit même faire plus rapide
et donc pour cela il y a une loi qui va
arriver mais aussi de mobilisation de
l'administration j'ai évoqué ce sujet
devant nos préfets il y a quelques jours
à l'Élysée qui est clé et je veux à cet
égard qu'on aille deux fois plus vite au
moins pour les projets renouvelables au
moins deux fois plus vite deux fois plus
vite alors pour répondre à cet objectif
et bien ce projet loi doit permettre de
lever certaines barrières juridiques
administratives qui ralentissent la
conduite des projets et puis pour
développer davantage les énergies
renouvelables et bien le texte va
imposer à des panneaux solaires sur deux
nouveaux espaces écoutez Emmanuel Macron
nous installerons plus de panneaux
solaires en identifiant tous les espaces
qui s'y prêtent en ville au bord des
autres donc en ville en particulier il y
a la question des élus qui sont même
savent bien des grands parkings avec
l'installation de panneaux solaires qui
permet de générer des revenus
complémentaires et d'utiliser des
surfaces utiles on va ouvrir aussi la
question de certaines friches de manière
très très simple on a la question des
bords d'autoroutes la mobilisation des
terrains disponibles pour y installer
des panneaux solaires
et puis l'enjeu c'était aussi de faire
mieux accepter ces projets d'énergie
renouvelables et notamment les éoliennes
terrestres il y a un problème
d'acceptabilité de la population sur ce
sujet et ce projet de loi prévoit un
partage de la valeur de l'énergie
produite par exemple par un champ
d'éoliennes cela pourra apporter et bien
à une remise d'électricité pour les
riverains de ces éoliennes s'il a des
chances d'être adopté par le Parlement
alors à première vue on a l'impression
que tout le monde est plutôt favorable à
l'écologie au développement du
renouvelable et qu'une majorité pourrait
se dessiner mais quand même ce n'est pas
gagné on le rappelle Emmanuel Macron n'a
pas de majorité absolue à l'Assemblée
nationale et du côté des oppositions
alors déjà le rassemblement national et
les républicains voient d'un mauvais œil
par exemple le développement des
éoliennes terrestres et puis à gauche on
est on dit attention c'est accélération
des projets d'énergie renouvelables
pourraient se faire au détriment de la
biodiversité donc là aussi méfiance à
gauche donc la ministre de la transition
énergétique en espagnol une va devoir et
bien liberté ce projet de loi et va
devoir aussi batailler pour le faire
adopter merci Alexandre
moi je suis plutôt favorable à
l'assouplissement en général les
procédures administratives enfin les
Français ont le droit de s'exprimer
aussi à l'égard de l'éolien ou du
photovoltaïque il y a en effet un
problème d'acceptabilité je ne parle pas
de des procéduresiers il y en a dans
tous les métiers et dans toutes les
activités mais il y a il faut savoir par
exemple que l'Allemagne ne vous parliez
à trois fois plus d'éolienne que nous en
avons dans notre pays et je pense que là
l'acceptabilité des éoliennes atteint
limite je suis l'élu d'un département où
il y a 300 éoliennes nous avons
pratiquement l'équivalent d'une petite
centrale nucléaire avec nos éoliennes
oui sauf que de temps en temps on a une
centrale nucléaire allez disons 1500
heures par an vous savez dans une année
un vieux réacteur en panne merci de me
laisser terminer il y a 8000 heures par
an et on a besoin d'électricité pendant
8000 heures et nos éoliennes nous font
de l'électricité en moyenne les plus
modernes de 1000 heures par an
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut doubler les
installations éoliennes de production
thermique au gaz ce qui n'est pas très
intelligent mais là c'est un débat que
nous n'allons pas épuisé ce matin non
mais c'est quand même en tous les cas
ques
les photos voltaïques il faut savoir que
c'est dans nos latitudes 1500 heures par
an maximum le reste du temps il n'y a
pas d'électricité photovoltaïque et
l'éolien c'est 2000 heures par an
maximum c'est à dire que pendant 6000
heures il y a pas de d'éolien et on fait
comment à ce moment-là quand on a besoin
d'électricité la nuit il y a pas de
photovoltaïque et quand il y a pas de
vent parce que il y a des situations
climatiques sans vendre notamment
lorsqu'il fait très froid ou très chaud
et bien il y a pas d'électricité
sur le fait que c'est intermittent
finalement qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
ça le discours de mon excellent
collègues est un discours purement
franco-français d'une citadelle assiégée
c'est-à-dire que
l'Europe est interconnectée la Bretagne
va recevoir un grand câble venant
d'Irlande adosser à l'éolien offshore de
du nord de l'électricité ah non dans des
conditions Rais ou alors vous perdez les
deux tiers de l'énergie c'est pas vrai
c'est 5% sur les grands réseaux
moi je trouve
en continu puis le retransformer encore
internet la perte est beaucoup plus
petite que ça mais je pense qu'on a un
problème en France effectivement mais
moi je suis là pour discuter de ce
projet loi qui est améliorable qui a
progressé je pense que le fait que le
gouvernement est intégré la vie du
Conseil national de transition
énergétique avec la suppression de
l'article 3
le fait ça on était c'est un message que
j'avais passé à la ministre avec les
assurances de protection de
l'environnement qui tord de question
qu'on est en parallèle la vie de
l'autorité environnementale et la
déclaration du public dans la maintenant
on aura l'avis de t'aurais été
environnementale avant la déclaration
publique ce qui va aussi augmenter
l'acceptabilité des des projets je crois
que on peut pas se dire nous français on
a raison contre tout le monde alors que
massivement il y a des investissements
dans tout l'Europe combien à SF géant de
investi 4 milliards sur un parc éolien
offshore au large du Danemark parce que
c'est le moins cher pour sa propre
production notre risque si on développe
pas le renouvelable c'est le départ des
électrons intensifs parce que le
nucléaire est beaucoup trop cher mais
c'est je pense qu'on est sur des débats
totalement théoriques franco-français
qui ne correspondent rien à la réalité
européenne et encore moins à la réalité
mondiale c'est un vrai problème du débat
français mais c'est c'est un peu
ontologique du nucléaire surtout
aujourd'hui ce développement du
renouvelable passe par un certain nombre
non pas tant d'assouplissement de
diagnostic il a été assez bien posé par
la ministre non pas tellement dans la
loi mais sur le fait dire Emmanuel
Macron l'a dit aussi que les moyens
d'instruction des dréals des directions
de l'environnement et il y a une
circulaire au préfet sont trop longs
donc il faut plus de monde dans les
Dréal pour instruire les projets là on
perd beaucoup de temps qu'on perd
beaucoup de temps sur les recours non
suspensifs et que là la ministre des
fonds aujourd'hui un fonds de garantie
qui fait que les développeurs les
industriels pourront et seront garantis
si un certain nombre de recours à
aboutissent blog le parc mais les
travaux auront commencé parce que c'est
vraiment là le parc de Saint-Nazaire on
est le bon exemple c'était en attente de
purger tous les recours même les noms
suspensifs ce que propose la ministre
c'est que quand il y a plus de recours
suspensifs on attaque le développement
avec des fonds de garantie en cas de
risque juridique donc ça ça va faire
gagner beaucoup de temps et ça c'est
très technique et précis dans la loi
après ce qu'il manque dans la loi c'est
l'investissement citoyen c'est le rôle
des collectivités territoriales
notamment on va essayer de présenter un
amendement là-dessus on a des beaucoup
de territoire notamment Loire-Atlantique
qui veulent développer l'éolien et qui
essayent de le développer au meilleur
endroit là où l'acceptabilité la plus
forte là où il y a le moins de problèmes
de cohabitation
qui se retrouvent en fait des fois avec
un autre projet éolien parce qu'on a un
développeur qui a contractualisé avec
notamment des agriculteurs qui a déjà
les terrains sur un projet moins bon
donc moi je pense qu'il nous faut un
amendement pour dire si la collectivité
si la commune l'intercommunalité a déjà
un bon projet alors ça gèle de de
d'autres projets même si ces projets
sont passés au-dessus en achetant des
terres donc c'est ce genre
d'amélioration qu'il faut dans la loi je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui on a un dialogue
avec la minisquier qui est intéressant
et effectivement c'est l'avenir de la
France dans les 10 ans qui vient qui
viennent on ne fera pas de nucléaire
c'est le renouvelable qui sauvera
l'économie française c'est très clair
donc il faut y aller la réponse de
Charles avant d'aller à Saint-Nazaire
justement on va voir on va voir ce
projet éolien je n'ouvrirai pas le débat
sur Leclerc je pense exactement le
contraire et aujourd'hui les les il y a
plus de deux fois de les projets de
nucléaire dans le monde sont deux fois
plus nombreux que les 500 réacteurs
existants donc pour son investissement
sur nos lac dans le monde dans les pays
effectivement l'Allemagne pour des
raisons philosophiques que je peux
comprendre refuse le nucléaire c'est le
seul pays d'Europe qui le refuse la
Grande-Bretagne les Pays-Bas le la
Belgique revient les pays scandinave
continue le nucléaire donc mais c'est un
débat que nous n'allons pas ouvrir je
reviens sur la loi si une loi permet
d'alléger les procédures en France je
serai le premier enchanté de le soutenir
si c'est au bénéfice du renouvelable ça
doit être bénéfice de tous les projets
parce que la France est devenue un pays
où il n'est plus possible de conduire un
projet en moins de 5 ans 6 ans 7 ans
cette absolument insupportable
maintenant juste une observation sur le
l'éolien maritime pourquoi c'est
compliqué en France parce que nous
n'avons pas le même rivage la mer
Baltique ou la mère du Nord sont des
mers peu profondes et la profondeur où
sont implantés c'est ces parcs et ce
sont de l'ordre de 20 mètres 30 mètres
40 mètres nous nous avons un plateau
continental relativement réduit et par
exemple de où on plonge très rapidement
donc tant que nous n'aurons pas
d'éolienne flottables enfin qui
ancré et qui pose d'autres problèmes
j'ajoute que l'éolien je suis je
conteste totalement compris qu'évoque en
excellent collègue parce que
l'use des éoliennes maritimes et
l'entretien des éoliennes maritimes où
il faut se déplacer soit en bateau soit
en hélicoptère est absolument ruineux
mais c'est pas grave vous le découvrirez
à l'usage et justement on va aller chez
vous dans votre département à
Saint-Nazaire c'est Audrey Vita ce qui
nous y emmène dans le premier parc et
aux liens en mer de France qu'Emmanuel
Macron a inauguré la semaine dernière il
produira 20% de la consommation
énergétique de votre département rendant
20% de temps en temps au total cumulé
Gérard long
partage
il faut faire 15 km de bateau pour
approcher ses 80 géants d'acier de 210
mètres d'eau nous sommes au large de
Saint-Nazaire au milieu du tout premier
parc éolien offshore de France qui voit
enfin le jour après 14 longues années de
projet et plus de 2500 réunions
publiques à terme il produira 20% de la
consommation électrique du département
de Loire-Atlantique on avait un grand
nombre de défis sur le sur le parc
éolien des défis techniques et des défis
qui n'échappent à personne c'était que
c'est le premier parc éolien en maire de
France donc effectivement on est on a je
dirais ouvert beaucoup de voix que ce
soit réglementaire humaine arriver à
inscrire un parc éolien dans un horizon
de vie c'est quelque chose qui prend du
temps la réalité aujourd'hui est visible
elle est bien évidemment et j'en suis
très heureux conforme à ce qui avait été
imaginé il y a des années Emmanuel
Macron lui-même en visite sur ce tout
nouveau parc a salué un jour heureux
avant d'annoncer une accélération de la
France sur l'éolien en mer le président
voudrait 50 parcs comme celui-ci d'ici
2050 et il y a beaucoup d'enseignements
à tirer du chantier de Saint-Nazaire sur
l'environnement d'abord les associations
de protection de la nature disent avoir
été écouté notamment sur le métal
utilisé pour protéger l'é sous l'eau le
premier sélectionné était toxique pour
laisser tasser une méthodologie EDF à
accepter de changer méthodologie au vu
des alertes portées par les gens des
cétacés et la pêche donc on a été
relativement entendu et on a bien été
dans la réduction des impacts
la prévention a quand même été de
prendre en compte ces impacts et de
créer des alternatives on dirait que
c'était un chantier model ou pas
c'était un chantier pilote je dirais
modèle on verra si le modèle est suivi
et si on peut améliorer le modèle la
petite commune touristique de base sur
mer a aussi des idées pour améliorer le
modèle son paysage est l'un des plus
chamboulés par les éoliennes sur ce qui
s'appelait la côte sauvage on les voit
beaucoup sur le paysage ça impacte
énormément
je dirais même la nuit plus que dans la
journée parce que la nuit il y a des
petits clignotants rouges ou blanc mais
comme un comble bah sur mer et l'une des
municipalités qui percevra le moins
d'aide compensatoire car elles sont
calculées sur le Nombre d'habitants à
l'année
2880 contre 18000 l'été la commune
compte de très nombreuses résidences
secondaires qui ne sont pas prises en
compte dans les indemnités le parc
éolien en soi et c'est une très bonne
chose la seule chose que je regrette
c'est les indemnisations moi j'espère
simplement que l'horlogue va peut-être
être un peu plus importante et
contiendra compte effectivement de des
résidences secondaires voilà pour que ce
soit un petit peu plus juste quoi le
président a promis que la question des
indemnités serait repensée dans le
projet de loi énergie renouvelable qui
arrive au Parlement
puisque c'est chez vous d'abord la
question des paysages vous avez entendu
la mère de Bad qui dit mais on les voit
et on les voit surtout la nuit et puis
la question des indemnités est-ce que ça
c'est quelque chose que vous allez
travailler alors d'abord je crois qu'il
faut le redire c'est un parc où les
anciens 3dictions de l'environnement ça
a été dit n'était pas contre où les
pêcheurs qui sont étroitement associés y
compris pour amener les techniciens sur
les parcs en attendant la corrosion
enfin pour l'instant encore aux ions je
sais pas si c'est l'eau salée qui est
responsable à la cohésion des tuyaux nos
vieilles centrales nucléaires en tout
cas il y a beaucoup de corrosion mais
donc je crois qu'on a réussi à
Saint-Nazaire mais aussi parce que c'est
là je parle de mon territoire un
territoire industriel avec un
savoir-faire les turbines de Général
Electric sont construits sur place c'est
évidemment les Chantiers de l'Atlantique
on le voit sur cette sur cette image qui
feront là la sous-station électrique
donc ça correspond à la fierté
industrielle c'est moi je suis pas
contre la technique c'est un très très
belle objet technique un grand parc
éolien offshore et c'est effectivement
tout le tissu industriel de
Saint-Nazaire qui a été associé après on
les voit les éoliennes et y compris il y
a des effets loupes en mer qui fait
qu'elles sont on les voit des fois plus
grandes qu'elles ne sont il y a cette
question de la pollution lumineuse
nocturne sur lequel je crois qu'il faut
effectivement revenir tout le monde en
parle après le ratio effectivement la
ville de Saint-Nazaire reçoit une
indemnité importante mais dans les côtés
le câble passe aussi dans Saint-Nazaire
donc il y a eu aussi des désagréments
très importants pour la ville de
Saint-Nazaire moi je pense que
l'enveloppe globale pour les
collectivités territoriales doit
augmenter l'enveloppe globale sur
l'éolien terrestre pour la protection du
patrimoine
architectural comme naturel doit
augmenter moi je pense qu'on déposera un
amendement Gérard Longuet nous
soutiendra peut-être pour finalement on
utilise l'éolien terrestre aussi comme
un moyen de financement pour notre
patrimoine humain comme comme naturel on
a besoin d'argent et là peut-être une
source de financement et pour en avoir
discuté avec les les industriels de
l'éolien ils sont pas contre cette idée
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui se fait pour
l'éolien maritime je crois surtout qu'on
n'a pas encore dans la loi la manière de
vraiment associer les collectivités qui
sont prêts à financer son pré-investir
notamment à travers techniquement ce
qu'on appelle pipi le Power
personnellement agrement c'est-à-dire la
possibilité dans les appels d'offres
c'est pas possible aujourd'hui d'avoir
des investissements beaucoup plus fort
des des collectivités donc on a on a des
marges de progression de de ce projet de
loi parce que en fait en
Loire-Atlantique on le dit pas assez moi
j'inaugure régulièrement des parcs
éoliens terrestres et plusieurs de ces
parcs n'ont jamais eu de recours y
compris sur les communes de droite donc
l'acceptabilité beaucoup plus forte
qu'on le dit même si ici là on a
quelques cowboys dans les développeurs
éoliens qu'il faut un peu recadrer
non mais le projet techniquement
passionnant moi j'adore la technique
j'adore l'industrie et si la métallurgie
permet de lutter contre les corrosions
la corrosion de l'air salé qui est quand
même assez sévère vous savez en marine
on a l'habitude de on disait toujours
tout ce qui ne se salue pas ce pain
cette sur les bateaux de guerre parce
qu'il foutent peindre en permanence
protégé contre la corrosion en
permanence c'est une certitude vous avez
en plus des problèmes techniques de de
coordination et de réseaux entre les
différentes éoliennes et les câbles
sous-marins c'est pas une affaire facile
mais techniquement c'est un beau projet
ce qui est ce que je pense profondément
c'est que le le coûte du Mégawat produit
lissé sur l'année complète c'est-à-dire
non pas quand le parc fonctionne il
fonctionnera mais il fonctionnera une
partie du temps de l'année et une partie
non prévisible or l'électricité a une
particularité c'est qu'aujourd'hui on ne
sait pas la stocker les conditions
satisfaisantes et donc il faudra le
problème de l'éolien c'est que quand il
produit il est utile mais s'il n'y a pas
de client en face ça ne va pas et si au
contraire il y a des clients et que le
parc ne produit pas ça ne va pas non
plus donc c'est pas un système de base
c'est un système de complément et dans
mon département j'ai toujours soutenu
les parc éoliens quand les mers les
demandaient parce que c'est une façon de
à travers l'ifère il y a un impôt qui
s'appelle l'hyper un pot forfaitaire sur
les entreprises de réseau et chez nous
c'est partout d'ailleurs en France
j'imagine on partage entre la commune
d'accueil les intercommunalités et le
département et c'est très accepté mais
ce n'est pas une solution que globale
pour l'ensemble des besoins énergétiques
et la réponse très rapidement le dernier
mot
à la réalité européenne à
l'interconnexion des réseaux et au
développement de l'hydrogène à partir de
miser sur la question est-ce qu'on peut
miser sur le là pour assurer notre
indépendance énergétique de l'éolien
c'est 40 euros le stockage hydrock gen
c'est 30 euros le père c'est 120 euros y
compris avec le stockage d'hydrogène et
des vecteurs non ce sont des vrais c'est
les chiffres de Bloomberg c'est bloomber
c'est plus vos amis que moi c'est c'est
la réalité on arrive à la fin de ce
débat la réponse que vous contestez les
chiffres de Bill Gates et je vous
renvoie à son livre qui est tout à fait
remarquable un homme qui a fait ses
preuves en gagnant de l'argent n'est pas
complètement idiot Bloomberg aussi c'est
une agence qui reprend les idées des
autres ça n'a rien à voir c'est
poursuivre ce débat on espère que vous
reviendrez nous voir sur ce plateau il y
a encore beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
dire tu renouvelable elle est importante
et il faut rester sur sa loi nous nous
projetons pas dans 15 ans on sera dans
un autre pays bah alléger des
dispositions administratives pour une
fois dans ce pays je serai enchanté moi
vous êtes d'accord là-dessus et on en
parlera évidemment de ce texte quand il
arrive au Sénat
[Musique]